Ecuador vive su semana política más
convulsa en los últimos dos años que han
estado marcados por una dura lucha
política entre la presidencia de la
República liderada por el presidente
Guillermo lasso y la oposición dentro de
la asamblea nacional una asamblea que
cerró esta semana el presidente lasso
tras decretar la muerte Cruzada durante
el juicio político en su contra por
presunto delito de peculado así con
cierta tensa calma han vivido los
Ecuatorianos esta semana
hay una relativa calma primeramente
porque no ha habido más infestaciones
esperemos que de esto llegue ya cuando
se termine cuando ya haya las próximas
elecciones si se pidió el congreso es
como que no ha habido ni no ha habido
congreso no ha habido nada es como el
que tuviéramos no estuviéramos ahorita
ni presidente no estuvimos no tenemos
ahorita presidente Pero qué toca
nosotros toca luchar seguir adelante
porque el país en el país que estamos es
duro duro está ahorita el Ecuador tras
este cierre del Congreso se convocaron
elecciones extraordinarias ahora será el
Consejo Nacional electoral el que deba
dar una fecha fija tentativamente serán
entre el 20 y el 22 de agosto de este
mismo año una selección es para las que
Aparentemente el correísmo llega con
ventaja tras haber ganado las últimas
municipales
Solamente los que salieron están
buscando la forma de volver a ingresar
donde que sacan plata súper facilito y
de una forma Casi casi gratis solamente
ganan gente oportunista gente que se
aprovecha de la cultura de la gente de
los de la gente que necesita
es una decepción terrible que tenemos
ahorita actualmente en a nivel político
una vez el presidente Guillermo lasso ha
declarado que no se presentará estos
comicios ahora el juego político ha
habido hacia el interior de los partidos
y de las coaliciones electorales que
buscarán a los mejores candidatos para
ser el próximo presidente de la
república